nevada highway patrol says this
morning's rain helped cause that crash
luckily though nobody was seriously
injured victoria saha has been over at
the scene all morning long she's live
this afternoon with an update victoria
the scene here just actually cleared up
a few minutes ago traffic is moving
smoothly as you said john right by that
i-15 southbound lane i am also learning
that a total of four rescue officials
were inside that truck as of right now
three of them have been released the
fourth is being evaluated at the
hospital
as the rain came down it took rescue
officials hours to get the fire engine
off its side on the 215 eastbound and
i-15 south ramp as traffic was blocked
off from the area a heavy crane was
brought in to tip the truck back up then
placed on a tow truck the fire engine
was coming this way on the highway but
you can see here this is when it started
to skid off the road and then over here
it started to flip and then slid back
onto the ramp on the highway clark
county fire department deputy chief
warren whitney tells us the wet weather
had a role and this situation is not
common i don't know i don't know how
fast they were going i'm assuming that
they
you know were
had adjusted their response due to the
rain but
i mean you've all seen traffic sometimes
it just locks up and you got to stop
with it that original rescue call that
this engine was heading to was for a car
accident and a person was trapped deputy
chief warren says there was no delay in
rescuing that person
that fire engine involved in that
rollover was an older model and it will
not be repaired reporting near 2 15 and
the i-15 southbound
ramp excuse me victoria saha live local
now